[Music]
the world of comic books is a very
interesting place usually our eyes catch
events like crisis on Infinite Earths or
you know flashpoint which set the stage
for new 52 Marvel's civil war House of M
different things like that but because
these major events oftentimes
interesting stories interesting stories
slit by us and the result is that we
miss out on sit on some thrilling tales
and so we turn our attention now to 1972
with Luke Cage Hero for Hire issues 8 &
9 where he battles Doctor Doom
so initially Luke Cage is approached by
this guy and the guys like hey man I
need your services and Luke Cage is like
not interested man I got other stuff to
do so he bails out he goes off and does
his Luke Cage thing really battled some
criminals whatever is Luke Cage he's got
unbreakable skin you know yet a tijada
anyway he returns from his business he
comes back and the dude is still there
and the dudes like hey look man like I
really need to hire you and he's like if
you're done doing whatever it is you had
to do then you got time for my business
so Luke Cage is like are I fine cool
what's up and the guy's like okay look I
got this employer right this guy that
wants to hire you for like 200 bucks a
day and all you have to do is find like
four dudes and track him down and he's
like they're hanging out in the hood
basically this is 1970s like language
here guys so don't blame me that's
basically what it is like they're in the
ghetto they're in the red so Luke Cage
is like all right cool so he goes and he
searches all throughout you know these
places he starts following Clues and he
starts tracking people and eventually he
starts attacking one of these guys well
it turns out the guy's a robot and Luke
cages like man what in the hell is going
on like this dudes a real pilot says
this is not make a single bit of sense
so the other guys take off right and
Luke Cage tracks him down ends up
following him to like the embassy hotel
all right he goes into the embassy hotel
he starts like threatening people
because Luke ages and put up with
anybody he starts threatening
people and then dr. doom shows up and
doctor dooms like dude you don't touch
my guys all right
do not lay your hands on the people that
work for me and so Luke Cage is like
alright well then like the end you need
to answer some questions that I have
like what in the heck is going on here
right now and doctor dooms like well
actually I'm the one who hired you like
I hired you indirectly through that one
guy and Luke Cage is like well why did
you hire me he's like well you know and
please bear with me on this guys this is
1970s uh race relations were a little
different back then dr. doom says that
he had robots that worked in Latveria
for him and some of the robots took off
and they came to America and they
disguised themselves as black men but
because Latveria doesn't have black
people doctor do he needed a black guy
to infiltrate the hood and figure out
who these robots were and then ephra him
them which is why he hired Luke Cage Wow
so doctor dooms like okay look he's like
the guys that I'm looking for the robots
and I need destroyed are at this address
alright here's the address so he gives
him the address Luke Cage goes out there
he starts hunting around he finds the
robots and he was like curtains and he
just starts taking these robots out all
right like it's drapes I mean he's he's
crushing him he's like beating there has
the stone and then to stuff I mean
they're just they're getting totally
plumb well meanwhile Luke Cage has like
indestructible scans slide they're not
really able to harm him now after he
takes all these robots out like he goes
back to the embassy he goes back to the
embassy hotel alright he's trying to
find dr. doom and the Bell man's like
are you Luke Cage and he's like yeah man
I'm Luke Cage I'm trying to find dr.
doom and he was like well dr. doom has a
message he says dr. doom was watching
your fight he thanks you for destroying
the robots but he ain't paying you at
all like dr. doom stiffed him on the
check basically so at this point Luke do
this comic is amazing so at this point
Luke Cage is pissed right so he's like
dude come hell or high water man I'm
getting my money like I'm getting paid
for the work that I've done so he goes
he's like dr. doom is a villain of the
Fantastic Four right so he's like we're
going to go to the Baxter building and
we're going to take a ship from the
Fantastic Four and we're going to go to
find dr. doom
there's no two ways about that's just
all there is to it so he shows up at the
back ship building right and he was like
time to get a ship and so he basically
just like breaks in as on the fan has
like four like dude what are you doing
man you can't just come breaking into
our place and he was like I don't give a
damn like I need to ship and I need to
get to to Latveria I need to fight
Doctor Doom and this is gonna happen you
know and that's just that's just all
there is to it and so they they fight
each other for a little while all right
but like luke cage's
overpowers the entirety of the Fantastic
Four Ben Grimm Johnny Storm the whole
nine yards well after it all you know
after your body calms down Reed Richards
is like hey everybody chill look this
guy's whooping us we cannot take a
Matthew shear force we need to reason
with him
Medusa of the Inhumans is there for some
reason I don't understand and and
they're like what's what are you looking
for a man like what why are you here and
he was like well dr. doom hired me for a
job and then he stiffed me on the check
and I'm gonna go to Liberia if I'm
getting my money one way or another so
so the Fantastic Four were like all
right they're like here you can use a
ship and just get out of here man you
can use the ship and you can go to
Liberia so Luke Cage is on his way to
Liberia right and and Doctor Doom
realizes that he's coming and so doctor
dooms like ah I did not expect this guy
to show up all the way here to collect
200 bucks this is it this is the problem
so we start sending US forces after Luke
Cage and Luke Cage is like not putting
up with us we just go starts going
through and like crushing every single
enemy that Doctor Doom has at the same
time you've got people who were working
against Doctor Doom to try to take him
down
and so basically Luke Cage starts siding
with some rebels and they fight
different robots to so on so for he
fights different foes but he ends up
getting into like the lair of dr. doom
and doctor dooms like dude did you
really come all the way here yeah did
you really come all the way here to
collect your money more to the point and
this is why this is why I say this comic
is crazy dr. doom literally says when I
got word that there was a crazy black
man wreaking havoc in my land I had to
know like I knew that it was it was
going to be you and and so Luke 8 is
like dude like I came here for the 200
bucks you owe me and like I'm getting
that 200 bucks
either either I'm taken out of your
Becky counter I'm taking it out of your
ass so so doctor dooms like all right
the series like look man I'm not just
gonna give you $200 this is not gonna
happen and so Luke Cage is like all
right man
- oh like like bouquet starts taking it
to him search hammer and dr. Doo now the
problem here is that Bob doom is strong
well he has all kinds of magic and all
that kind of stuff you know Luke Cage
has unbreakable skin and so dr. doom
can't really do anything against him you
know and and while dr. doom is bragging
while he's giving us really cool lines
you took out the thing he took at the
Incredible Hulk uh at the end of the day
you know Luke Cage is like you may have
taken them all out man but you have not
fought the cage like you I really hope
you guys put that in the comments he
said you have not fought the cage all
right and so so Luke Cage is taking it
to him uh he's um he's pummeling his
armor I mean he's he's whipping Doctor
Doom out and so finally dr. doom is like
all right dude you know what man he's
like this is more hassle than it's worth
alright I'm not no I'm not I'm not
dealing with this anymore so he's like
okay fine look he's like if you came
here for $200 and you're willing to go
through all this for 200 bucks man than
here just take the $200 and get the hell
out of here and so Luke Cage is like
cool well he gets his 200 bucks and he
was like man it's a day and so he heads
back alright he takes the ship he takes
taken back to the Fantastic Four cuz
Luke cages is like he's like he's on a
jerk or he's like just gonna like leave
the ship in a parking lot and then just
go home so he goes he drops it off at
the Fantastic Four's Baxter building the
pen has before like hey look man like
art like we've seen some headlines about
some crazy guy that rolled into Latveria
and just like ret dr. Doom's
stuff like like he he just many big he
brought down the Thunder so he's so so
they're like what what happened like
what did you do down there and Luke Cage
like man I saying and like he get
he leaves he just leaves
he doesn't tell him anything he was like
I'm not giving you guys any information
Ben Ingram's man he just like throws the
papers on the ground he's pissed off and
that's it like that's the end of the
story this is probably one of the
greatest stories of all time Luke Cage
vs Doctor Doom oh man we need to do some
more crazy stories like this that the
rundown was made for these kinds of
stories uh if you guys have ideas for
crazy stories like this that you think I
should do post them down in the comment
section because
I am really interested to see what you
guys end up coming up with but anyway
yeah if you guys are not part of the Rob
core make sure you guys hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob core make sure you guys leave a
comment down below tell me what you
thought about this series make sure you
guys drop a like and again make sure you
leave a comment let me know you know
what kind of care do you think we should
do next and yeah so I will catch you
guys on it
peace
[Music]